thousands packed the my dawn the day
after ukraine's parliament voted to oust
former president viktor yanukovych after
months of opposition protests the square
has now become a place of triumph
celebration and morning with Yanukovych
gone activists have been reflecting on
what the future holds i-i'm then we have
fought for this for over two months many
are dead they weren't supposed to leave
us they were young they never
experienced life all the politicians
associated with the regime should leave
Ukraine in a special session on sunday
ukraine's parliament voted
overwhelmingly to temporarily hand the
president powers to speaker alexander
turchinov touching off is a strong ally
of former prime minister yulia
tymoshenko he is also an outspoken
opponent of ousted President Yanukovych
potential candidates for the presidency
are already stepping forward opposition
leader Vitali Klitschko said he's ready
to lead if people decided I take
responsibility Klitschko will likely
face off against Timoshenko in an
emotional speech on the Maidan late
Saturday the former prime minister said
she would stand in Mays elections she
called on Ukrainians to keep fighting
and reminded them of the two years she
spent behind bars you thought I was
imprisoned thinking there was no greater
joy than to be born and live among you
because you were the best but now we
have important tasks ahead and first of
all we have to bring Yanukovych and all
the scum gathered around him to my done
but deposed President Yanukovych still
enjoys strong support in Ukraine's
eastern provinces in Crimea
demonstrators gathered in protest of
yanukovych's ouster they called
politicians in Kiev traitors and
fascists and refused to recognize the
legitimacy of the new interim government